YOU CAN SEE THEM THERE WITH THEE
MIDDLE AND BIT.
BLUE JACKETS. BIAS. JUDGE  BELI.
SHAKING HIS HEAD THERE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE PCKET SET OUF
THE ZONE. MR. MACK.
HE HAS WON A STANLEY CUP.
WE'VE GOT TO GO WITH REGAIN THEA
ON HIS CHEST.
THERE'S A PASS ACROSS
DOWN TO AN EVEN BLOCK.
IT IS AUTOMATIC
OUT FOR THE EXTRA ATTACKER.
RIGHT
LONG SHOT BRUIN'S OWN.
>> HERE COMES OLIVEIRA CROSS
1.8 SECONDS LEFT ON THE CLOCK.
HE.
LOOKED LIKED NOW THE JACKETS WID
OFF EYES.
THE DYING.
ONE TIME
CHOOSE TO GO FIRST IN THE
SITUATION. THE FIRST SHOOTER FOR
THE BRUINS.
0-2 FOR A SHOP FULL SEASON.
GAMG
GOALS.
A SHOOT-OD LIKE HE
MIGHT'VE CAUGHT HIM MOVING.
GOAN
GAMES COMESES RIGHT. THIRD SHOO.
>>